So welcome back to statistics 101. Today, we're going to learn something insanely cool.
You might remember from the very beginning of this class that we had
data sets that involve more than one dimension.
For example, the size of a house is relative to its price, and initially, we talked about scatter plots,
we talked about bar charts but we didn't talk about what's the holy grail of statistics,
and that is fitting a line through the data points.
After this unit, you'll be able to fit a line to data points like those
and you'll even be able to tell me what the residual error is in that fit, and that allows us
not just to understand the data but also to make predictions about points we've never seen before.
So let's dive straight in--so let's talk about lines and let's talk about the technology
to fit lines to data called linear regression.
It has two dimensional data such as the age of a person
and the person's income and this is obviously made up data.
Then linear regression tries to fit a line that best describes the data.
So how do we specify a line--suppose we call the horizontal x as x
and suppose we call the vertical axis y then the lines commonly described
with a functional relationship between x and y of the following form y=bx+a.
So let us look at lines. Let's take this simple example y=2x.
Let's add units to the axes of coordinate system and let me draw 3 different examples of lines.
The blue line, the green line, and the red line and for this example y=2x.
Can you imagine which of the three lines would be described for this equation.
Please check one of these three boxes.